joining me right now prior to calling
bucks and saints on westwood one
is once again worthy of congratulations
because he's a pro football hall of fame
finalist again
because of his stellar work with the
jacksonville jaguars who are in the news
he's also a jaguars voice he is our
friend tony besselli how are you tony
rich i'm outstanding how are you doing
happy new year
same to you bud same for same to you so
let's get right to it um
people going crazy in duval county right
now i mean urban's in the fold
tony it actually happened what do you
think
yeah like christmas yeah christmas came
like two uh three weeks late
for uh the jaguar fans i mean i think
you know this isn't you guys know this
is an organization over the last decade
that has been
you know not very good outside of 2017
and
you know sean conn's gone through a few
head a couple head coaches and
gm and everything else and they've never
gotten it right and haven't had the
consistency
um that obviously anyone's looking for
and he's
it's not like he has not invested and
tried to figure it out
and i think he said hey i'm gonna i'm
gonna make a splash
i'm gonna go big and i'm gonna swing for
the fences and get a guy that is a
proven winner and although he's not done
in the pros we know the history of
college coaches going to the pros but
i think it's a good bet i mean here's a
you know you guys know
his resume and everywhere urban meyer's
ben he's won so there's a lot of
excitement right now and you couple that
with the having the first overall pick
and
assuming it can be trevor lawrence fans
uh have a lot to look forward to
so tony um what are your concerns about
what you just mentioned because
obviously there there have been college
coaches that
succeed in the pros um last year alone
even though
um they they did not come close to
making the playoffs i think everyone
could say that matt rule
does have a handle on what it's like to
be an nfl head coach but
pete carroll as we all know might wind
up in the pro football hall
of fame even though he was a
professional football coach before he
was a college coach
urban's never really had much time in
the pros at all
what are your concerns on that front
yeah
[Music]
well i think that's the big difference
bridge is you know
we've seen guys who started the nfl went
to college and they came back
and they've had that success you know i
think
what you're looking at is guys who's
never been in the nfl and all of a
sudden you know
they come up to you know the next level
the next stage
and so there's always that concern but
if we're honest with each other aren't
you concerned about every new head coach
that comes in the nfl i mean there's no
guarantees
i mean that's why we see the turnover
every year
um of coaches and this year with seven
coaches losing their job so
i think you have to you know just make
the best
i don't want to educate a guest but you
have to look at all the different
factors that go into it
and try to find the right fit and i
think you know
when it comes to uber meyer it's about
his resume and everything else we talked
about
and when you look at concerns you would
say
how does a college coach who is been
able to recruit and get anyone he wants
and dealing with younger men 18 to 22
how does he how transition to you know
guys who are in their 30s have families
i mean it's a it's a job
but urban you know he's a natural leader
um i think he's been doing a lot of
research talking to a lot of people over
the last
year or so to learn about the nfl and i
think
i think he'll be prepared because he's
not and he's also not the typical coach
who comes up and is a defensive expert
or an offensive expert
and that's why you're hiring them you
hire a reminder because you're looking
for the best leader
and that's what he's done in college and
i think that's what we'll bring to the
jaguars and
and the big risk i believe two big risks
yes sir
one is what does the staff look like
he's got to get that right the right
offensive coordinator defense corner
because he's not a play caller
and so first and foremost see who he
hires there
and then secondly who is he paired with
at the gm
the press conference today they had shot
on the owner and him said that
they're talking about it expecting
announcements next week or so who that
individual is obviously urban will have
a lot of say in it
but you got to get the right next uh
right gm next to him because your player
procurement
is critical everyone knows the nfl
so look i know he's uh and we're going
to play this soundbite later on
uh tony biselli here on the rich eisen
show uh i we're gonna play the soundbite
later on i mean uh
uh urban urban has already made it seem
like it's an open question whose first
overall i mean
please there's a river and it should be
cried to me i mean like it's definitely
going to be trevor lawrence here and the
question is is how do you think
his game translates to the next level
and it's going to be fantastic how does
he work in like what sort of system do
you think needs to be run
and the offensive coordinator married to
him what do you think on that front tony
vicelli
well first thing is i mean i can't
imagine not being
uh trevor lawrence i mean to your point
i mean i think that's pretty much i
think we're all lying there
and and and i think learn from the
mistake the colts made
they got andrew luck amazing talent
and they didn't build properly around
him and i'm talking about the offensive
line
and so first and foremost you want to
build the right system around him
starting with the guys up front to make
sure he's protected
and then as far as schemes and what kind
of you know you want to try to
adopt some of the concepts and stuff
you've had success at
um at clemson he's a great athlete he
can run the ball
but he's also a pure drop back
quarterback we've seen him operate from
the quarterback so i think he
i mean the reason he is so highly rated
is because
when you look at him on film you're like
he can do it all this isn't just a guy
who has to run zone read
and work you know out play action and
move in the pocket and using his legs
he can do that but i think he's an
effective uh
pocket quarterback as well now he's have
to develop and learn and
identify defenses and all the
progression that every quarterback goes
through as they come in the nfl
but when you watch him on tape there's
not a lot of holes in his game and i
think
as an offensive coordinator it gets you
pretty dang excited where you want to
keep it as you know not simple but basic
as you build it up
um but i think i think everything is in
front of him and i think you can throw
i might i imagine you'll be able to a
lot a lot of different information and
teams and everything at that's
good tony posella here on the uh the
rich eisen show i can hear you moving
around i don't know if you're driving
are you driving to the airport to go to
new orleans in the bucks right now no
not yet i was actually i'm getting i got
in my car i'm sitting down now
i'm so i'm the older i get it's like
doing two things at once rich i just
don't have the same skill set i once did
but no
getting ready to head somewhere so i'm
sitting down now okay
all good so uh what a game is tony i
mean
you know tony i we we we hype stuff
that's what we do for a living in in the
paparazzi in the nfl but
truly you can make this this is maybe
one of the most remarkable playoff games
in match-ups we will ever see that we've
ever seen and we will ever see
because of who's quarterbacking and then
the circumstances
that we've already seen between these
two in brady and brees and obviously
where they both rank on the all-time
list and now they're playing in a first
playoff game against each other and it
could be the last game of drew brees's
career
or the last run of drew brees's career
with brady
hoping to get where he wants to go in
his first season outside of new england
i mean the stakes the story lines could
not be
any bigger how do you think this plays
out tony beceli
well richie said it perfectly because
every playoff game's huge and this is
bigger than the mall this weekend
and when i found out from howard
denneroff at westwood one that i got to
go do this game i was pumped because
all the story lines are there the
history of the game great quarterbacks
future hall of famers what happens next
you know drew brees probably this could
be it this could be his last game if
they don't win so
um it's fabulous the saints obviously
swept the series they dominated the
buccaneers in that last match up 38-3 it
wasn't even close
in watching and thinking about that game
what do the bucks have to do different
um they're a better team now they've
improved throughout the year the timing
and everything
brady looked outstanding in that game
against the washington football team
so you expect you know a high level uh
his best
um but i really think it comes down to
can the buccaneers establish
some sort of run game think back to that
big blowout loss they abandoned it
buyer left did not call the run he tried
to spread out the saints he tried to
drop back
and put it all on brady and brady's
great uh but in that game
they couldn't hold up against the rush
the saints have a really good front four
they got after brady pressured him over
35 percent of the drop backs and
they had no chance so i think leonard
fournette ronald jones is back
he was questionable uh in practice
yesterday um but if they can get
i mean i'm not talking about russian for
150 yards or anything obviously it's
still going to be brady and those great
weapons he has at the tight end and wide
receiver position
but if they can't at least slow down and
and have
uh close to a balanced attack i think it
i don't think they can beat the saints
the sanchez is too good defensively in
but if they can get a little bit of that
play action pass open up the middle of
the field
uh get the saints out of that too high
uh safety look that they like to run and
play two man
may force them to come and stop the run
uh then i think
brady and that offense can be effective
and i think we could have a different
outcome of the game well i mean we know
what the low
uh water mark is in terms of what you
got to beat in order to have a better
run game balance is
eight yards which is the total number of
yards they had on the ground against
the saints in that sunday night and we
had fournette on the show earlier this
week and he said they embarrassed us
and you know that's in that's in the
back of their minds um
where do you where do you stand on the
evaluation of this offense
playing as well as it has all year long
they've been going to cook with gas is
it because they did play against atlanta
twice in the lines and they got enough
uh sea legs under them to beat a a a
much more stout washington football team
or
or this is going to be the the test that
they might not pass
against the saints what do you think
here tony
yeah i i mean i think it's i think it's
an evolution rich um
you know if you look at this i mean they
they took a lot of pieces
brady who's been in one system his whole
you know his whole career you get gronk
throw him in their year off you know you
throw in antonio brown
i mean you've got a lot of different
things and you're trying to figure out
who you are and what is your identity
identity and remember no off-season
limited camp
i mean just covet and everything that
gone into it
and i think it's taking time for them to
get in the rhythm get comfortable for
you know brady and left witch and aryans
all get on the same page of what they
want to do and i think the stretch down
the run for them was critical of just
from a
uh you know confidence more confidence
in timing
and it's amazing you say wait a second
confidence tom brady the tv confidence
you know
gronkowski mike evans these are great
players not in individual
their individual ability they didn't
need confidence but confidence
of how they all work together in the
timing and knowing where guys are going
to be
and what brady wants and and brady
reading the body language of his
receivers and
how they where they want the ball that
all takes time and it takes reps and i
think
you saw that then get better and better
as the season went on
and i do think this is a different game
i'm not saying the buccaneers are going
to win i think the saints are fabulous
on defense they are so good
they've done a great job alvin kamara is
the difference maker
how do they match up again against him
not just stopping to run but out of the
backfield he's such an effective
receiver
and so but i do think we're going to see
a very close game
i think it's going to be back and forth
because i do expect the [ __ ] years
offense to be light
you know light years ahead of where they
were when they lost 38 to three and i
think they learned from it i think buyer
left which the play caller
understands that hey i have to establish
the run
i gotta at least have the threat um of
running against that um
saints defense to force them to put an
extra guy in the box and to open some
things up outside
tony buselli uh bless you sir congrats
again on another
uh uh hall of fame finalist year and
may this be the year you you get what
you deserve which is enshrinement
you know how i feel about it tony rich i
appreciate it
and uh you know i'm disappointed i won't
see you guys down at the super i know
unfortunately this cove is going to
limit all of our at
how we can move around down there and
what we can do um but wish you guys the
best
youtube always loved being on the show
and uh hopefully next time
i'm with you guys uh you can introduce
me with a little bit of a different
uh title because uh hopefully the whole
thing goes my way
come on tony here we go lfg as the
patriots would say thank you for the
call tony you take care
hear it you go that's tony becely hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here